if fury road wasn't enough to convince
you that Charlize Theron is a bonafide
hardcore action star case closed
atomic blonde I called this this past
weekend actually at a drive-in and it's
been a while since I've been in one it
was a pretty good time so this is the
latest movie from one of the two
directors of the first John wick and
obviously it's going to beg a fair
amount of comparisons to that movie now
I actually think I might be able to stay
spoiler free on this one for the most
part just because the plot isn't really
the point although the movie thinks it
is I'll come back to that but let's
start with what's good pretty much all
the performances Charlize Theron sells
the heck out of this character
especially in the action scenes James
McAvoy really does that wonderful line
of being fun to watch but also really
sleazy you've got Toby Jones and John
Goodman as sort of an mi6 and a CIA guy
respectively and they're both just great
actors to have around they always are
sofia boutella is on hand as a French
operative and she's really cool so the
setting on this thing this is a cold
war-era spy movie set like right up to
when the Berlin Wall is about to fall
and set in Berlin so here's the thing to
make the comparison to John Wood because
like I said you kinda can't avoid that
John wick which is an awesome movie
understood that the plot such as it was
was the excuse to get from action scene
to action scene and knew as a resultant
to make not a stupid plot but a simple
plot this doesn't do that now there are
action scenes that and they are great
but there's only about four of them and
unlike John wick which understood the
story wasn't the reason anyone was there
atomic blonde thinks it has a story
worth telling and well it's not a bad
story if you've seen any cold war-era
spy movies you kind of already know what
you're in for something that is
simultaneously almost inscrutable but
completely predictable what I mean by
that is you're going to have a very hard
time figuring out who's on what side and
working for who and doing what
yet at the same time be able to plot out
the beats of the whole thing almost
exactly so whereas the movie is
constructed as though the action scenes
are the icing on an already delectable
story what happens instead is the action
scenes become the reasons to see the
movie somewhat in spite of the story now
I do want to be clear though the action
scenes even though they are not as
consistent in terms of how often they're
presented as they were in John wick are
the reason to see this movie there is
one fight in particular which is this
knock-down drag-out fight that happens
at stairwell spills over into an
apartment it goes on and it alone is
worth the price of admission this scene
is epic and it is awesome and it is the
first one with that I have caught since
they live that shows the exhaustion that
is involved in a long very physical
hand-to-hand fight and it just sells
that well I would argue even better than
they lived it but it's just something
you don't see that often but this movie
that hits hurt you feel the exhaustion
that these characters are feeling but it
doesn't get old doesn't get more you're
not left going oh god is this fight
stealing is still going on you're
instead left going oh my god how are
they even still moving and they barely
are now even though the fight scenes are
the reason to be here the characters are
fun it's just the story they're being
asked to move in like I said is
convoluted when it absolutely didn't
need to be the way that this thing was
what the strength of this thing are
really needed something with a stripped
down story this does not have that at
all now I've talked to someone who's
read the original comic book that is
based off of and said that the story
presented on screen is representative of
what the comic book is so it may have
been a case of they just didn't know
when to adjust more from the source
material I can't speak to that
personally but I will say if you like
hard-hitting action and if you like
Charlize Theron you really kind of can't
go wrong and like I said even though too
much time is spent on a story that isn't
as good as the movie thinks it is the
action scenes are worth seeing it at
least once that one turned out kind of
short I think my thoughts are just
they're pretty succinct on it so have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down on the comment
let's talk about it don't forget the
like subscribe check me out on Twitter I
council of geeks give a listen to a
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]